[موسيقى]
جمال الحي العتيق لمدينه بون لا يكمن على
السطح فقط بل ان الكنز الحقيقي لعاصمه
النبيذ لمنطقه بورجوم بالشمال الفرنسي
اختفي في باطن الارض انها اقبيه تحتوي على
مليونير زجاجه نبيذ متراميه على مساحه
خمسه كيلومترات مرصصه ضمن قاعات متصله
ببعضها البعض احد اقدم الاقبيه في المدينه
يعود الى دار دغوه منذ اربعه اجيال يديره
اليوم
يخفي بين ثناياه شيئا من اثار الماضي
العريق للمدينه
تقع اغبيه المنزل فيما يسمى بالكاست هوم
اي المعسكر الروماني كان اول حصن غالي
روماني لمدينه بون في القرن الثالث تقريبا
الرومان الذين وصلوا الى بون كان اول هدف
لهم هو حمايه انفسهم من الغزاه والبرابره
فلم يقوموا طبعا بانشاء الحواجز الخشبيه
بلشيدوا اسوارا وجدران صلبه من خلال تجديد
الحجاره فوق بعضها البعض على شكل عظام
السمك بواسطه ميلات صلب سميك
هذا القبول المشيد وفق النمط القوطي من
قبل رجال الدين في كنيسه بون في القرن
الثالث عشر مازال يقدم خدماته حتى الان
تحتوي هذه البراميل على اخر ما انتجته هذه
الداره في هذه الصلاه القديمه ادخال
الماكينه ضمن طريقه العمل امر غير وارد
الذي المسافه طويله نوعا ما لذلك لابد من
المعرفه الجيده بكيفيه تحريك هذه البراميل
التي نخرجها ونوعيدها مره او مرتين في
السنه حتى لا نؤتي ايدينا ما نتيجه تركنا
لهذا القبول سيتحول الى متحف ثم تسكنه
خيوط العنكبوت ثم بعدها يختفي عبقه نحن
متمسكون بنقل جميع المعارف الى كل
العاملين في هذه الدار
[موسيقى]
نقل الخبرات والسردها عبر الاجيال هو
النهج الذي سلكته دار الشومبي اقدم دار
تجاريه في منطقه لابوغون من خلال انشائها
لمتحف يحكي تاريخ 300 سنه نجد مثلا في
صفحات ذلك التاريخ شخصيات مشهوره مثل
الويب ستور عالم الاحياء الذي مر يوما من
هنا لدراسه النبيذ ومحاوله تطويره
بمجموعه من الابحاث في دار الشامبي وفي
المنطقه المحيطه كمدينه
سيكتشف مجموعه من الميكروبات والخمائر كما
سيكتشف عمليه التخمر الكحوليك
الشخصيه الشهيره الاخرى التي تركت بصمه
على هذا المكان هي
تعرف على هذه الدار في نهايه القرن التاسع
عشر حين كانت تجوب انحاء العالم وتقيم
المعارض للتعريف بنبيدها وبيعه
عام
1889 انتقل الداشامبي الى المعرض العالمي
وهناك التقدم مهندس المعماري الخارق الذي
شيد برج ايفل الرائع وقررت حينها ان يكون
هو من يشاهد معملها الجديد لصناعه النبي
الاعمده المشيده من قبل ايفل لا زالت ترى
حتى الان ضمن المعمل اما في الاسفل فتوجد
الاقبيه التي تعود الى القرن الخامس عشر
هناك اغبيه يمكن زيارتها مثل هذه التي نقف
بها الان لكن لدينا ايضا نقبيه نضع فيها
نبيذنا تمتلك دارو الشامبي شبكه من
الاغبيه الممتده على مساحه
قديمه ونبيض يعتق وسط براميل من حطب
البلوط
تحت حراسه امنه ومشدده ترقد بعض الزجاجات
هنا منذ 160 سنه كي تشهد على تاريخ طويل
لزراعه القرون في مدينه بون منذ خمسه قرون
تقيم هذه الدوره المخصصه لمساعده
المحتاجين عمليات بيع بالمزاد لارقى انواع
النبيذ من اجل المساهمه في تمويل المستشفى
العام
[موسيقى]
ليس بعيدا عن هذه المباني والاقبيه التي
يبلغ عمرها مئات السنين تقترب من واحد من
معامل النبيذ الجديده
جادو الذي انشئ عام
1996 وفق معايير وتصاميم حديثه جعلت منه
انذاك اول قبول معاصر لمنطقه
قررنا حينها انشاء معمل نبيذ خاص يناسبنا
تماما ويساعدنا على العمل
كلما شعرنا بالراحه في مكان العمل كلما
كان النبيذ جيدا في النهايه
لذلك قررنا انشاء معمل واسع يسهل تحركاتنا
فيه حتى تكون طاقه العطاء فيه افضل
الشيء الحديث الاخر هو انشاء هذه القبه
المفتوحه على الخارج امر نادر في هذا
النوع من المباني حيث يتم في الغالب تجنب
عنصر الاضاءه كانت لدينا رغبه في الاتصال
المباشر مع ضوء السماء ليس كثيرا طبعا لان
الاضاءه الكبيره ليست مرغوبه ضمن معمل
صناعه النبي
نحتاج فقط الى شعاع من الضوء ينير هذه
الاواني والبراميل ويدفعنا الى الارتقاء
نحو الاعلى عندما نرى معمل النبيذ هذا
نشعر بفرح وسعاده لانشائه
بعد 27 سنه على انشائه استطاع المعمل ولوج
صفحات التاريخ الطويل لتقليد مدينه بون
العريق واقبيتها العديده وما تخفيه من
كنوز